c'est un havre de paix symbolique dans
l'histoire du pays basque il y a dix ans
le conflit opposant le groupe
indépendantiste eta à l'espagne à la
france prenait fin ici dans le palais
d'aiete à saint-sébastien ce 17 octobre
2011 une délégation internationale
emmenée par kofi annan rencontrait des
membres de letea des politiques
françaises et espagnoles mais aussi des
membres de la société civile basque et
les acteurs du processus de paix le pays
basque sortait d'une dernière tentative
de négociation entre l'état espagnol
heures et l'état et le thé à qui avait
échoué et devoirs de voir tous ces
personnalités internationales à venir au
pays basque avec pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de ce conflit
l'ensemble des acteurs politiques
des territoires historiques présent à y
était ça avait de nouveau
impulsé l'espoir parmi eux brian currin
médiateur reconnu qui a déjà oeuvré en
afrique du sud et en irlande du nord en
partie grâce au travail de ces hommes de
l'ombre pour la première fois le monde
évoque ouvertement un conflit que madrid
et paris ont du mal à assumer
seule tête et il fallait ouvrir des
voies de communication entre les
différents groupes et partis du conflit
c'était mon rôle était de se cacher et
windows
cela a contribué à ce que le thé a et la
gauche indépendantiste changent leur
agenda politique
ah oui c'est ce qu'ils ont fait et c'est
ce qui a fait du pays basque ce qu'il
est aujourd'hui
que des trois jours après la conférence
d'aiete le groupe indépendantiste
annonce dans un communiqué mettre un
terme à un demi siècle de lutte armée
le début d'une décennie de stabilité
malgré la difficile réconciliation
permet et chemin
koutchma la seule chose qui reste
problématique aujourd'hui c'est le
statut de victime et la question du
pardon et de la réconciliation
une blessure que les partis politiques
utilisent parfois à des fins électorales
veut
dieu
le gros mâle moi je dirais de ce
processus là aujourd'hui il ya cette
guerre de récits permanente qui
n'empêche pas de manière sereine
d'appréhender la complexité de ce
conflit là on ne construira pas les
réelles garanties du non-renouvellement
de l'histoire si on n'est pas capable
dans ce territoire de permettre que tous
les récits puisse exister et cohabiter
aujourd'hui certaines cicatrices ne sont
toujours pas refermées
la polémique autour du sort réservé aux
anciens membres de l' eta prisonnier
politique ou exil est toujours
d'actualité mais la société civile
espère recréer un nouvel élan retrouvé
l'esprit d'aiete et construire une
feuille de route pour les dix prochaines
années